I have kids and I want to start an only
fans because it generates more income do
you think that's a good representation
of my kids and my husband I was on a
Henry recently and uh one of the girls I
just met her on the head and I have
before she was actually a virgin when
she got married and she said her boss
she had I think it's a bell I don't know
do you have any fans like a a
bachelorette okay okay yeah so yeah
we're on a bachelorette and she's heard
she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like I've heard that sound before
where's that from she'd heard it on Tick
Tock it's from only fans turns out him
and his wife have a BDSM only fans
they're married with kids do you think
that's an optimal environment for kids
to grow up in with um basically anyone
can pay ten dollars and see their
parents having sex